So, we started out practicing how to
roll a stationary staff down the neck
into an arm spiral.
So, what we're doing is kind of taking
the end of a steam or minimal steam.
We're learning the end and then working
back around. So, learn the whole move.
So, the idea is that if I'm rolling it
down my left arm, I want to hold the
staff to the left of center by a little
bit and I want to place the center to
the left of my head a little bit. So, as
I roll it down, I can also push it
around into a horizontal spin. I'm
giving it roll by coming down, pushing
around into a spin. So, we get roll and
spin, which equals a spiral.
So, we're spinning it down,
practicing balancing on the arm.
Another key concept we played with is
that when a staff is spinning, if it is
spinning too fast and it's going to hit
you in the head, all you have to do is
turn your body with staff and now it's
not going to hit you in the head
anymore. So, that's a a key instinct you
should develop whenever you're learning
staff moves. If it's getting too fast,
just immediately start turning with the
staff to stabilize it. So, we're rolling
around, going down the arm, turning our
body, letting it roll up. We're
practicing looking at the center,
feeling the balance point of the center,
and keeping that on the arm. If it gets
too far off the arm, it's going to fall.
If it gets too far in the arm, it's
going to fall into you.
So, we practiced this a few times.
Practicing balance, practicing balance,
practicing balance. Then, we added a
cross
contact.
So, this is two points of contact.
Single point of contact, you have to
balance. Two points of contact. It's
much easier to balance and you have
control over how fast you're rolling and
spinning. So, as we come down and
around, as it gets onto the shoulder,
you bring your other free hand
underneath behind the staff
and contact. You can transfer to the
other arm. So, it comes down and around
cross contact and that transfers to the
other arm very nicely. The whole time
you're doing this,
you can adjust how much it's spinning
and you can adjust how fast it's
rolling.
Whenever you have two points of contact,
you can control roll speed and spin.
So, we did this
cross contact to here.
And then finally, when that was
comfortable, as it's rolling down
towards the neck, that's when you need
to dump underneath it so that the dragon
staff can keep rolling so it doesn't
stop rolling. So come down the neck
around, cross contact,
dug out,
and keep it going.
So that's a big part of what we learned.
Then what else we do? The forearm thing.
Okay. So
we also played with
as this is rolling down
from from the cross contact rolling down
the arm like Steve or next arm spiral
instead of ducking out as it rolls down
the forearm you lift your elbow up right
as the staff center gets the elbow you
can bring your arm in hand to the
armpit. Let the staff roll down the
forearm and take it out back to the
start. So that looks like this. Roll
down, elbow up, take out,
back up. And eventually
you can get comfortable
running that up and down over and over
again.
Uh the final bit that we practiced,
we practiced another two points of
contact transfer to go from standstill
to uh speeding a roll up and flipping it
over. So you take the center, put it a
little bit inside the arm you're placing
it on. With the top hand, you're rolling
and pushing and flipping over.
So if you can do that, which is flipping
vertical, we can also do that spinning,
flipping horizontally.
So you're going to start up here. You're
going to roll along this arm. You're
going to give it a spin, push it around,
and let it roll down the forearm off the
elbow. Here it is from the front.
Here it is from the back.
Once you get comfortable with that,
right as it's getting to your elbow, you
can also lift your elbow up and tuck
this out. So, this looks like this. Lift
the elbow, tuck the arm under, and it
rolls back up to the fingertips.
So once it's rolling back at the arm,
you have the choice of a cross contact
transferring to the other hand
like that.
You can also instead of just rolling the
forearm, instead of popping the elbow
up, you can lean your arm back and roll
all the way down to the armpit, even
down the side of your body. So we just
started practicing this. You guys can
take it home and play with it. So, we're
going to roll it here. Lean back and let
it roll down the side.
And eventually, you can even
catch the staff behind your back. Turn
it around this way
and practice on the other side.
Like, so that's extra credit takeaway
homework. Okay, that's pretty much what
we covered. And yeah, there you go.